i'm not [ __ ] leaving
i think that what you're seeing is um
essentially a push back against the
establishment
in a really important way you know
coming out of 2008
what happened was wall street took an
enormous amount of risk
and they left retail as the bag holder
and a lot of these kids
were in grade school and high school
when that happened they lost their homes
their parents lost their jobs and
they've always wondered like why did
those folks get bailed out for taking
enormous amounts of risk
and nobody helped and showed up to help
my family
instead of having idea dinners or you
know
quiet whispered conversations amongst
hedge funds in the hamptons
these kids have the courage to do it
transparently in a forum
and i'm not saying all of it is perfect
by any means
but i think it takes an enormous amount
of
faith in the system to be that
transparent to talk about things and
then for each individual to make their
own mind up
and to do things what's better than a
bank
investing your assets for our profits in
the safety and security of the stock
market
if you go on the reddit boards i've been
on there for a while they
understood that there was admit there
was a mistake being made by the big
hedge funds
by going over 100 percent short the
outstanding float in
gamestop they saw a vulnerability i
don't know why other hedge funds didn't
attack this
but retail banded together and they
attacked this as they should have
the sec should be investigating the
hedge funds for allowing this
vulnerability to be in existence in the
first place
not the people that took advantage of it
that's capitalism
you